[Music]
in inside job news Oh submitted by
watermelon season eating that [ __ ] every
day it starts like at the end of July I
think it was like yeah earlier now it's
ending it's about to end so get as much
as you can hurry an investigation an
investigation uncovered that
Ticketmaster has been running its own
professional scalping bracket oh [ __ ]
always felt like I knew that something
was always going on like that
we Ticketmaster their shake not just
take your master but like all those
companies like StubHub whatever don't
sue me but I just feel like there's a
lot of those things going on where
you're like like they'll sell the
tickets for our concert right and it's
like 50 bucks if you buy it a year in
advance but no one's buying concerts
like a year in advance but then as soon
as it gets like a month out or two
months out all of a sudden the $50
ticket is now $800 ticket and then the
week of it's like a $3,000 ticket and
then it's like perfectly Oh a pair of
seats for you and your whatever and I'm
like I feel like there's like insider it
feels like insider trading where people
they just know so they know they can
inflate these prices and then they just
hold on to them it feels like that but I
never really it's you can't really know
so it's weird that this isn't
speculation it's like it's an
investigation that like where they do
well hop oh yeah so these so CBC what
CBC Canadian I don't know what it's an
ad and vigilantes Oh CBC CBC Canadian
Broadcasting channel probably so they
went undercover to this Las Vegas expert
like this convention it's easy for
Canadians to go undercover to because
they look like American and they speak
like
Americans until I say a couple of words
hmm so I don't know what they're talking
to me
hey yeah sorry for interrupting I just
wanted to let you know you left your
boots upstairs oh my mistake
don't get hurt now make sure you go to
the hospital if you get hurt doesn't
matter we have helped carry Oh I'll
invite Seth Rogen over oh and Justin
Bieber a drink
oh uh Jim Carrey but that's why I say
like Canadian vigilantes they were like
something's going on in America and
we're gonna go rescue like that's Oh
Thank You Canada come save us you can
for saving us yeah so they went this
investigative journalist went undercover
as a scalper at this ticket industry
convention and oh there's a convention
there's a convention for literally I
wonder if there's a coupon convention
there might be a haiku ponders for sure
I think of something really random and I
bet you those kids clip convention
probably you know the chip bag clip
maybe it's part of the chip industry
doughnut box convention well we part of
the donut convention or maybe packaging
convention I'm pretty sure they have
that yeah I'm pretty sure that go veg
for everything mm-hmm so yeah this
investigator he was talking to
Ticketmaster and they were saying that
they have this resale division where
they've turned a blind eye to scalpers
who use ticket buying BOTS and fake
identities to grab so shitty tickets and
then resell them on their sites because
they own this other site called scalper
dot-com hey Jeff
I'll trade that desk
so they own the scalping site or a
resale a resource a particular site and
so they inflate the prices and
Ticketmaster what they're doing is
they're cashing in on double the fees
first the scalper like when they're
grabbing the tickets they yet you know
they get the Ticketmaster for you from
that and then when they sell the tickets
on trade death they get another feet
that's smart hmm yeah but that's not
right yeah cuz when you get these
tickets to because I bought it off one
of these reseller sites before it's
always anonymous so you don't even know
who yeah and they take a certain
percentage you know like the hell's
going on here
scalping is illegal cuz why no it's
what's happening in sneaker culture too
is it's it's not the fact these people
are not buying stuffs not as we go to
that the fact that they're programming
these BOTS that are faster than humans
and can buy these tickets or buy these
shoes and then you could just yeah so
it's not fair it's also it's illegal
because everything says on it not for
resale so your recent so by putting that
statement on it and then you resell it
you're violating that we're just leaving
the supply of tickets in one day
yeah a family emergency I guess I'm like
like a billionaire right and then I
wanted to make more money for some
reason and it's like oh [ __ ]
LL Cool J gonna come back on tour or
something right and I buy out all of his
tickets I think you're gonna be stuck
with a bunch of tickets I know maybe you
should get Drake tickets
fine okay okay I'll do Drake's new new
album tour or whatever and I buy all the
tickets and I resell it at my price
which could be double the price of them
whatever you sell your pretty much I
kind of making your money back on those
tickets that didn't sell because you
marked up the tickets so high yeah and
then the artist is playing to a sold-out
house yeah I just don't understand how
that's
maybe maybe I got a dose like don't
knock baby or maybe you're not paying
taxes on the profits you don't have a
resellers permit that that I can see cuz
I'm also like okay what's the difference
between that than people buying from
wholesalers and then buying from like
the shoe game you need to tell you
though it's not illegal everywhere oh
okay it's only a certain place that
certain states yeah cuz some people do
that where it's like Oh limited-edition
shoe so then you go into the store you
buy all the limited-edition shoes and
then you try to sell it for even more
online yeah me know I mean that's why I
like people say like a lease in a
sneaker well that sneaker culture that
you know back in the day you be up at 5
a.m. and you're lining up with these
bunch of strangers but you are
interacting and stuff but now it's like
one dude can buy all of it and be his
own business and we yeah you know yeah
and it wasn't met and it wasn't meant to
be put on the market for that it was
meant to be put on the market for
individual sales yeah so like morally
your dick well I mean and also the the
artists for like concerts they usually
set the price of their tickets and so
take a master's class a link mmm this
isn't good enough for us let's sell it
for more like you know yeah that's
probably like they're from the valley I
don't know why I don't know why give me
I think you've alley girls that run the
company I think what's even like shadier
and this whole thing is the fact that
Ticketmaster cracks down on other
scalpers that use box and stuff they
don't worry they're going through their
own site which is trade desk they turn a
blind eye they're like okay you could
use your body because I you could sell
all of these tickets that's funny that's
like um so some of my friends worked
security at a rave and then so we we can
sell drugs there but they would bust
other drug dealers because they're
taking away from business yes so I was
like that's like the same thing that
hurt oh well maybe it was like a but I
think when they owned one of the
so that they like they know they're
gonna lose profits on scalpers anyways
and so like what if they like bought the
business to keep it from doing that and
then they'll go into it anyway no [ __ ]
that's like yeah I think I think my
favorite part about this whole story
though is the Canadian journalist went
undercover to find out about like a
thing that like actually kind of matters
like I feel like lately it's always like
like I'm broke magellan and I think that
pigs are being sexually harassed and
factories undercover like you know like
I think it's kind of cool that they like
investigated that yeah yeah cuz we're
not worrying about our real issues but
they are like I don't know like they're
doing some real work buy tickets copy
that's don't win journalists do like the
police's job instead of like celebrity
gossip or some [ __ ] yeah they're
actually helping Society and if the cops
are like we're calling oh man they're
making it look bad nothing like they
want yeah like true journalism whereas I
feel like a lot of journalism now is
like four clicks you know
well they got who though cuz like to do
a long ass investigation infiltrating
[ __ ] and like like the like wit when
they did I think it was the Scientology
religion like I think it was twenty
twenty or one of them they went
undercover and and they like it took
like months or maybe even years to like
expose them to cover this whispered I'm
gonna get you dude
yeah you ditch the Church of Scientology
she can't even say is that I'm holding
more [ __ ] now dude there's like I
don't know it's just weird they have
like a bunch of they own some abandoned
buildings near where I live like I don't
know it's just really weird and like
with it then you're cool with it right
like you don't have an opinion yeah I
love Scientology it's mad chill like
whatever you guys want to do you do it
were you guys a part of the Ticketmaster
class-action suit
oh yeah so they had a huge class-action
suit where they're there
Ticketmaster fee they were illegally
charging too much and not notifying the
customers you know pretty much a
five-dollar fee for going through
Ticketmaster
right yeah somebody did an investigation
and found out that they were they didn't
like legally properly give people a
heads up that that charges for the
specific the hell is shady forever dude
go to see geeks dude class-action one
and like I got three bucks but sometimes
those fees are a percentage yeah you
order thousand dollar ticket your fees
like $200 things like it wasn't
consistent like it was just changing all
the time so it got shady is kind of hmm
so Ticketmaster as like been shady and I
don't understand it if you're making
good enough money why the [ __ ] you
trying to be so stupid want you yeah cuz
the more money you make the more safe
the safer you have to be because of [ __ ]
like this hmm but I rich just want to
get richer yeah people just add on weird
fees oh it's a Hollister the other day
and I looked at my receipt and at the
bottom it said I was charged for
sentence for a facility fee why that's
right and you know what my cheap ass
turned around and I said I'm sorry I
just wanted to know like what the [ __ ]
is this and she was like oh it's just
like you know keeping the lights on and
I was like are you yeah that's not
supposed to be budgeted into the item
that they're selling I have no idea I
was charged a facility me
yeah super serious it was so weird you
know about the restocking fee yeah I get
that that makes sense to me because it
takes labor to put it back on the shelf
well not that but like repackaging it
like you have to retype it or we
whatever you know like I understand that
yeah but that I don't get yeah or what
about Post maids charging me an extra
like I don't know like you know when you
put it flick through a postman sorter
and it's like mmm subtotal $21 you're
like this is reasonable and at the end
you end up paying like $34 you're like
how did that [ __ ] get here I'm always
ordering like $15 Bulba because I always
got paid a post mates fee but the boat
was too good you go drive and get the
boba I don't know whether they'll
twinkle twinkle little stars
[Music]